have um gotten a chance to hang out
quite a bit in the metaverse with Mr
Mark Zuckerberg recently and boy
is the realism in there or the new like
the the thing that's coming up in the
future is incredible I got uh scanned uh
in uh Pittsburgh for 10 hours into the
metaverse and there's like a
uh virtual version of me and I got to
hang out with that virtual version do
you like yourself well I I never like
myself
but it was easier to like
that other guy that was interesting I
was like you
he didn't seem to care much it's
actually lack of the empathy
but that was you know it made me start
to question even more than before like
well how important is this physical
reality because I I got to see you know
myself and other people in that
metaverse like the details of the face
the like all the all the things that you
think maybe if you look yourself in the
mirror are imperfections all this kind
of stuff
when I was looking at myself and then
others all those things were beautiful
and it was like
it was real and it was intense and it it
uh it was scary because you're like well
are you allowed to murder people in the
metaverse because like are you allowed
to because what are you allowed to do
because you can replicate a lot of those
things and it's you start to question
what are the fundamental things that
make life worth living here as we know
as humans have you talked to Elon about
his views of we're living in a
simulation maybe and how you would
figure out if that's true yes there's a
constant light-hearted but also a
serious sense
that this is all a bit of a game one of
my theories on Elon a minor theory is
that he read Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy once too often
yeah and as you know there's a scene in
there that says uh
that there's a theory about the universe
that if anybody ever discovers the
secrets and meanings of the universe it
will be replaced by an even more complex
universe and then the next line Douglas
Adams righteous and there's another
theory that this has already happened so
I'm gonna try to get my head around that
but I know that Elon Musk tries to well
there there's a humor to that there's an
enormous humor to Hitchhiker's Guide I
really think that helped musk out of the
darkest of his periods to have sort of a
sense of fun of figuring out what life
is all about